the difference between along with ants
and other animals they need this process
of learning they learn by imitating they
learn by observing so that's why we
create this forest schools where they
can learn from each other this is the
master animal rescue center for
orangutans in Japan we have now hundred
and two along with and we come across
along with ants that are kept as pets
illegally we also rescued them from the
habitat that is disappearing when we
rescue around and especially when they
are a small babies these babies have
lost their mothers normally and along
with them will remain with its mother
for as long as seven to eight years of
their lives and this is the process when
the origins have the chance to learn
from their mothers how to survive in the
world what to eat what not to eat what
are the ten years of the forest what we
have to do is to teach them how to
survive in the world in these forests
schools one of the first ones is how to
be off the ground how to spend time on
the top of the trees which it might seem
like a very simple thing but actually
some of these orangutans have been
living with people and having chained up
or living in small cages at the
beginning they are afraid to climb a
tree the ultimate goal of this
rehabilitation is release these animals
back to the wild what is special with
the wrong witnesses they are very
similar to humans if we don't care about
wrong returns I think it's even more
difficult that we are going to care
about any of the other species if they
get a stinked in Indonesia they will be
extinct from the face of the world so we
have to do something about this now